oh my goodness guys I don't think I've
ever seen this is the new M3 Pro MacBook
a disappointment because Apple actually
downgraded four separate things with the
M3 Pro chip So today we're going to do a
real world test comparing all of the
differences with different programs and
real world tasks and answer the question
should you just buy a discounted M2 Pro
MacBook Pro for a lot less or get the
new M3 Pro but first I want to take a
look at the Des design because this is
the first time that I am seeing this new
space black color and let me tell you
guys this thing is gorgeous now some
people are complaining that it's not
black enough and under the studio
lighting it does look brighter than a
dark black color but in other rooms it
does look nice and black and I think it
looks amazing and with that we have the
Mac safe cable where it is color
matching on the aluminum and then the
cable is Black by itself too which looks
super nice whereas with the space gray
you have the aluminum matching and this
is kind of like a very light almost
white gray now as far as the displays
they are practically identical the only
difference is that the M3 Pro actually
hits 600 nits in SDR compared to 500 so
you get a little bit more brightness now
as far as speakers Apple didn't mention
any differences but some years they do
make changes sometimes for the worst so
let's go ahead and compare them
somewhere
unar
back to where we
[Music]
started
out I don't know about you guys but to
our ears here the new M3 Pro actually
sounds a bit quieter than the M2 Pro
14in and we have seen that in the past
Apple toning down uh the Speakers by a
bit so that is a little bit weird now as
far as webcams this is the M2 Pros 1080p
webcam and studio quality microphones
and we will see if there's any
difference and this is the M3 Pro 1080p
webcam and studio quality microphones
and with the M3 Pro we have a new image
signal processor so you guys let me know
does it look any better and do the
microphones sound any better down in the
comment section below and now I
unscrewed the bottom covers and I want
to compare the differences that we have
and looking at it right away the first
thing I notic is that the heat block on
the M3 Pro is quite a bit larger than on
the M2 Pro it no longer has a smaller
section with this little pad and overall
it is much bigger and that could mean
that we're going to have better thermal
dissipation for the more powerful M3 Pro
chip now with that if you look over here
the M2 pro has a single nand memory chip
but there's three more slots that are
not used now this one does have another
one on the bottom side of the
motherboard but with the new M3 Pros
they got rid of four of the channels
that were available so now we have just
these two and two more on the back so we
have four channels instead of eight and
that is why the M3 Pro can no longer get
8 terab of ram like you could in the
past you have to get an M3 Max and now
let's test that SSD performance
difference but first I want to show you
guys that both of these laptops are at
100% battery so I'm going to go ahead
and unplug both of these and we are
going to be doing a battery life
comparison throughout all of these real
world tests and one thing to know is
that this machine is running at 600 nits
because we have that capability and now
let's go ahead and do our SSD speed test
both these are 512 GB machines and wow
look at this guys we have 4,200 compared
to
3,300 that is a nice boost in right
speeds and as far as Reed we have
4,600 compared to
2,900 so even though we still have two
of those nans they are faster and that
is a great thing before our next test I
want to show you guys the new
performance leather case made out of
genuine waterproof German hen leather
from our sponsor bandwork it's got this
beautiful two-tone design in a bunch of
different colors with clicky Aerospace
grade aluminum buttons and Camera bump
housing for incredible all around
protection with grippy indented sides
making it easy to hold and a super soft
plush microfiber lining on the inside as
well as maxafe magnets built in and you
can order one today by using the link in
the description with code Max tech23 for
a free 1oz leather balm and now I have
geekbench 6 opened up right here and the
first of the downgrades is the fact that
the M3 Pro now has 37 billion
transistors compared to 40 with the M2
Pro and if that doesn't mean anything
this is actually the first time Apple
has ever released a new chip that has
less transistors than the previous one
and the M3 and the M3 Max both have way
more transistors than the previous
versions let's go ahead and run this and
if you noticed the M3 pro has 18 gigs of
RAM compared to 16 and that is because
apple is now using three sticks of 6 gig
instead of four of8 and that is the
second issue that we are having where we
now have 150 g per second bandwidth
compared to 200 so the bandwidth is
actually 25 times less for the memory
now running this test here now I see
that the M2 Pro is running at 3.5 GHz
whereas this one the highest is going is
3.78 whereas Apple advertises as 4.05
GHz but we're not seeing it hit that at
all almost like it's a very rare case
that it could do so all right guys we
have our results and in single core we
have 3,7 compared to 20 2635 that is an
18% increase even though we never saw 4
GHz in the test which is advertised and
that is where it should hit it whereas
the M2 Pro did hit its advertised 3.5
GHz and as far as multicore we have
13,692 compared to
11,915 per increase in performance and
that is great and it's kind of
surprising because problem number three
is that for the first time ever in the
Pro chip Apple decreased the performance
scores so for the unbinned M2 Pro we
actually had eight performance scores
now with the unbinned M3 Pro we have six
two less cores and they gave us
efficiency cores instead but with these
base models we actually have five
performance cores on M3 Pro compared to
six so that is a downgrade but the
overall performance still went up and
now let's compare the graphics
performance running metal for compute
tasks and as you guys see we have 14
graphics cores compared to 16 in the
bend model and that is the fourth
downgrade we've never seen Apple make a
new chip that has less cores and if you
look at the power usage the M3 Pro hit
18 Watts Peak compared to about 23 so
it's using less power now and oh my
goodness guys I don't think I've ever
seen this our new M3 pro has worst
performance in terms of Graphics then
the M2 Pro
68,9 compared to
75,6 that is almost 10% less graphics
performance on a brand new machine and
this accounts for a wide variety of
compute tasks if we look down everything
that is actually being tested here and
that sucks and the only reason Apple
would downgrade these is to make the max
chips seem better both for CPU and for
GPU now we have a bigger separation
between them and you can buy buy this
thing on sale for roughly 1,600 bucks
compared to 2 Grand we have links down
in the description and now I have 3D
Marks Wildlife extreme open up right
here I'm going to run the unlimited mode
so it's not limited by the displays and
look at this guys thankfully we actually
have a better score with the M3 Pro 72.4
compared to 66.9 that is an 8%
difference and it is sad to only get a
8% gain but at least it's not losing and
this shows that for gaming Apple has
updated certain things to make it
quicker of course we have rate tracing
support now but for General compute
tasks we saw that decrease and now I
have figma open up right here a web
based application and this is a project
by 500 designs one of the best design
studios in California and as I'm zooming
in everything is nice and smooth let's
zoom in here everything's refreshing
super quick to get those high resolution
images the M2 Pro is also nice and
smooth and now I have 12 of these high
resolution layers selected and I'm going
to be exporting them so let's go ahead
and start my timer so the M3 Pro took a
minute and 21 seconds compared to a
minute and 38 on the M2 Pro and that is
a difference of
20% and that is a nice Improvement and
now I have logic opened up right here
and I'm going through these settings to
enable the best performance and one
thing I noticed is that logic is not
using efficiency core so here we have
six performance scores compared to five
and those efficient scores are now
really powerful more powerful than
before but this might not be even using
them and now I'm playing back 128 tracks
and you guys can look up the new logic
pro Benchmark and the point of this is
see what performance you can get and if
the system was going to get overloaded
and one interesting thing is that even
though we have less performance course
here we're only using 42% of the CPU to
do 128 tracks compared to 51 so less
cores is still able to handle more at
least for now and now I have 150 running
on both and the M3 just overloaded now
this could also be because of memory we
have less buffer but the M2 Pro is
running 150 tracks all right guys we
just did a bunch of testing and this is
crazy the M2 Pro handled
153 tracks compared to only 142 so the
M3 Pro can handle 11 less tracks you
guys can look into the whole Benchmark
uh if you'd like to but we have never
seen this where a new product an upgrade
is actually this much worse in
performance and that could definitely be
due to uh RAM the bandwidth is 25% less
uh and we know logic especially with
plugins and stuff does really utilize
Ram so if you use logic keep that in
mind now I have cinebench open up right
here and we are going to test the full
CPU performance as well as are thermals
for temperatures and fan speed I'm going
to go ahead and start the multicore
10-minute test and looking at our CPU
wattage looks like the M2 Pro is running
roughly 2 to three Watts higher um as
far as the requirements so this M3 Pro
with more efficiency course as you guys
can see we have six instead of four um
that is able to be more efficient now
the interesting thing is in terms of
temperatures we have 84 compared to 79
and the temperatures are rising up but
it looks like the M3 is heating up
faster and if you look right over here
our performance cores on the M3 Pro are
about 300 MHz faster the efficiency are
about 200 MHz so we have higher clock
speeds so looks like the two extra
efficiency cores are making up for one
less performance core and the M3 Pro
just hit 104° C compared to
101 so it is running hotter now our fan
um have kind of Spun up and it looks
like the new M3 Pro machine even though
uses less power it's running the fans
slightly higher but both these systems
are nice and quiet so it's been 6
minutes and I got out my thermal cam
let's go ahead and compare the
temperatures on the M3 Pro we're seeing
39° C where the chip is at compared to
44 dang we see actually a hot spot
that's much smaller whereas with M3 Pro
we had that larger heat block so that is
actually helping and this is actually
great news for the M3 Max and I actually
bought a 14in M3 Max so we're going to
compare that to a 16in and maybe this
year we will not see throttling like we
have in the past in a 14 in if you guys
want to see that video make sure you
guys are subscribed with notifications
enabled all right guys we have our
scores we have 865 for the M3 Pro
compared to 754 that is almost
15% gain with the new model and that is
actually pretty impressive it matches up
with geekbench and that does show that
those efficiency cores are doing some
heavy lifting now and now I have adobe's
Lightroom classic opened up right here
with 50 highresolution images all of
these are edited and I'm going to go
ahead and Export 50 of these this is
going to use the CPU the graphics and
it's really Ram intensive it's
interesting that this one's heating up
quicker and as far as performance it's
using more of the CPU and GPU uh
consistent instantly that might be
something with the new Dynamic Ram that
Apple talked about or other improvements
but the M3 Pro is flying along wow that
was way faster than I expected waiting
on the M2 Pro guys the M3 Pro did that
in 45 seconds compared to a minute and
six that's about 47% difference between
the machines and we were not expecting
that at all my goodness and to put into
context the new M3 that's 1600 bucks if
you upgrade that to 16 gigs of RAM that
will take a minute and six which is just
what we got in this machine and 45 is
just crazy fast so that is crazy this M3
Pro is going to be great for photo
editors and now I have blender open this
is the 4.0 beta which is starting to use
the raate tracing cores in the M3 Pro
and we are going to go ahead and render
this tough scene guys this thing is
flying it says we have 54 seconds
remaining uh compared to here over two
minutes guys it just got done this one
is a sample 88 out of 200 man that is
crazy and a great Improvement so we have
2 minutes and 13 seconds for the M2 Pro
in 57 seconds for the M3 Pro more than
twice as fast that's what closer to two
and a half times faster somewhere in
that range that is
incredible and what an update if you do
3D design and rendering and now I'm
going to run cen's new graphics
Benchmark to render using the GPU this
is the first time we're ever testing
this and oh my goodness guys I was not
expecting this big of a difference this
must be using those Ray tracing cores as
well because we have 2,821 compared to
5,526 that is almost double the
performance right there um pretty
incredible and that's crazy is if you
look over here this 14-in laptop is
scoring almost as high as an M1 Ultra
Max studio which that thing is what
double the price more than double the
price depending on that spec crazy man
that is pretty incredible can't believe
it and now I have Final Cut opened up
right here and I'm doing this 5 minute
export that has some effects and as you
guys can see it's running at the same
exact time and even looking at the CPU
and GPU usage they're pretty much
stacking up and that took 2 minutes and
20 20 seconds for that project just like
the M3 and even the M2 because the
encoders are the same and because the
performance and Graphics is refly the
same with some optimizations for regular
editing for most people you're not going
to notice any difference and because of
that I have this very tough AK prores
project as you guys can see it's going
to be 75 gab for this save I just want
to throw something at it that is very
difficult to see if we have any
differences and look at this guys we're
at 17 18% right now they're literally
identical and as far as the graphics and
CPU usage it's fairly similar this is
mostly Graphics uh related to do all
this processing um and man they are way
close all right guys that is done and
the M3 Pro actually beat out the M2 Pro
by 4 seconds both of them a little bit
over 4 minutes there so with that said
if you're a video editor even for tough
tasks if you want to save about 400
bucks and get the M2 Pro 14in discounted
you could definitely do so and you're
not going to miss out as long as you
don't want this black color and now
let's talk about battery life it's time
for the moment of truth because we've
been shooting for many hours even though
this video is cut down and let's take a
look at the M2 Pro this thing is at 133%
battery life remaining uh it's getting
low there and with the M3 Pro we have
27% more than double remaining and I
will say there are some times where we
have to download some programs on here
or redownload them because they weren't
working so in reality maybe it would
have been at 30% if we didn't have to do
that and we had the screen turned up to
600 nits as well oh yeah that's true we
did um that is very impressive in terms
of battery life so those extra
efficiency cores are helping and even
though we have less performance scores
they also make up for the performance
and in some tasks it made a huge
difference not only for 3D rendering and
stuff but Lightroom was 47% faster that
blew our mind so I will say we here at
maxtech were wrong about the M3 Pro
Apple did not send this to any reviewers
and based on their own announcement
video they said that the performance
increases were the same over the M1 as
the M2 had over the M1 and that kind of
let us down but in the real world this
machine is very very very nice so if
you're looking to buy a new Macbook yes
you can save 400 bucks and for some
people that will be worth it but overall
I would say that I would spend extra
money and for two grand you are getting
an excellent machine it's probably going
to be discounted as well check out the
links in the description below I love
the new color and man apple has a great
machine on their hands that most
professionals will be happy with um so
we like it a whole lot you guys go ahead
and click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there we're going to have a lot more
coming this has been Max and I will see
you in the next
[Music]
one